those afib has agreed to meet us
although he says he does not trust the
press so we you mind me recording our
conversation okay hip is a retired
police officer and a staunch supporter
of the Hong Kong government site in the
current crises aside that he feels is
not represented accurately in most news
outlets I start avoiding the news since
July watching just avoid or news to
report but you know because I can still
get in touch what was happening from all
those messages from my friends the
longer the protests last the most
Trident Li both camps refused to
communicate with each other internet
forums are shaping and polarizing
opinions in each group rumors and
conspiracy theories are rampant and when
both sides meet things often get ugly
[Music]
Alfred Wong is also a retired police
officer when he walks to his
neighborhood it is hard for him to miss
messages from the anti-government
protesters they have set up a so-called
Lenin wall near his home here it says
police are murdering people but in fact
the protesters are very aggressive the
police are just maintaining law and
order bomb has just returned from a long
stay abroad and says he doesn't
recognize his city anymore
in his spare time he sometimes helps out
at police stations as a volunteer
handing out food and drinks to the
frontline officers and while he says he
understands demands for greater
democracy he doesn't think they are
realistic why do you think is that
oddity much I used to serve in the
colonial police force then the British
government could decide on everything
now Hong Kong belongs to China KSAT pay
if there are problems that the Hong Kong
government can't solve it makes sense
that Beijing intervenes but fewer and
fewer Hong Kongers are willing to accept
Beijing authorities and the clashes
between police and protesters are
escalating with petrol bombs and bricks
being thrown by radical protesters and
police being accused of deliberately
hurting demonstrators and passers-by in
[Music]
a recent poll almost three-quarters of
respondents said that they thought
police was using excessive violence
Josef hip also started his career in
colonial times does not agree my time we
are taught that when rioters are
throwing petrol bomb at you you should
shoot them with live rounds
but now I think they are doing a great
job in the sense that they are they are
restrained he is glad he says that he is
not on active duty anymore so we've got
former police officers saying that the
force has actually acted with great
restraint all things considered I'd like
to bring in Mon K Tom of Amnesty
International Hong Kong to talk more
about this man k your organization is
demanding a full investigation into
police brutality what have you
documented well unfortunately MSD
internationals nuclear investigation
shows different conclusion we documented
an alarming pattern of the Hong Kong
police force
excessive use of force against
protesters and evidence of torture and
other new treatment intention for
example in several cases it had detained
the protesters have been beaten severely
beaten up during custody a man
for example detained at police station
and when he refused to answer for these
questions he was taken to another room
and then building up Sathya and was
threatened dare to break his hands if he
tried to protect himself and also during
arrests for example another example
young woman was locked down at the
ground and then police officers continue
to beat her after her hands were tied up
siipped ID so this kind of pattern
demonstrate that the police excessive
use of force becomes very common and
therefore we asked for a an independent
investigation against this kind of
evidence right but some of the
protesters have been violent I mean what
are police supposed to do if somebody is
lobbying Molotov cocktails at them well
in those cases for protesters throwing
great
petrol bombs if they use their violence
and I think that police has to let you
to make basis to arrest them but the
principle I mean international law on
the use
boss the principles are first they have
to stop that violence and and try to
minimize the force they use and most
importantly to preserve the right to
life but in many of the incidents that
we documented is what this wasn't been
his one learn the case right monkey tom
thank you thank you